game theory is a strategic theory in
which there are generally two or more
players so-called or actors and the
outcome of their game depends on the
choices of all the players so it's an
interdependent decision situation and a
mathematical theory was developed going
back to the 1920s but primarily in a
book by John von Neumann the great
mathematician and oskar morgenstern an
economist who were both a princeton
called theory of games and economic
behavior this book was published in 1944
and that really started the subject of
game theory and it's been applied in
numerous areas I'm a political scientist
so it's been applied to the study of
voting in elections to international
politics it's probably most prominent in
economics most of economics is now
written in game theory terms especially
microeconomics but macroeconomics
international economics as well it's
been applied to biology evolutionary
biology the evolution of species their
conflicts for examples in my work I've
applied it to texts including the Bible
I looked at the Hebrew Bible and the
twenty stories of conflict and intrigue
that I thought were most game-like and
starting with Adam and Eve and going
through most of the famous stories and
some not so famous I tried to show with
game trees and payoff matrices that the
biblical characters were by and large
rational God included I made
applications in political science and
I've also done applications to sports a
selection of draft players for example
in professional sports leagues so those
are something
apples
that's great i was hoping to walk
through a couple specific pacific
example you mentioned can use can you
take it walk us through a biblical
example of that okay i could try take
the story of Samson and Delilah in this
story Delilah a Philistine tries to get
the secret of Samson's strength and
makes three attempts do I was a woman
that Samson loves he very much dislikes
being harassed all the time for the
secret of strength but he refuses in the
first two attempts at the Iowa has
finally he succumbs and he tells the
secret of his strength and then bad
things happen afterwards so Samson gets
his revenge in the end and I think the
interesting question you can ask about
this story is how could somebody like
Samson be so stupid as to ignore several
warnings and my answer is that if you
look at Samson's previous career he
lusted after almost every woman he met
every beautiful woman anyway and Delilah
was the latest so you can explain his
behavior is rational in terms of this
interest in women allowing him to think
that he was taking a risk maybe in
telling the secret of his strength is
going here which of course was cut off
but it might not be disastrous in the
end it was disastrous Samson was
mutilated he was treated with derision
but he got his revenge he was placed
between two pillars his hair had grown
back at that time and he collapsed this
big stadium killing thousands of
Philistines so in games bad things can
happen and one can explain this in terms
of the rationality of the player's
actions and i define rationality simply
to mean that you make better you can
rank alternatives and you choose the
best alternative
but in a game it's more complicated
because you have to choose the best
alternative in light of what other
players may choose and that affects the
outcome but it doesn't depend on your
goals whatever your goals if you do the
best to achieve them I argue you're
being rational so if somebody desires to
commit suicide maybe somebody who's in
great pain and succeeds in doing so I
consider that behavior rational because
this was the goal of the person most of
us don't have the goal of committing
suicide most of us have other goals
winning in a contest and the like
getting as much profit as we can from an
enterprise but whatever the goals if you
choose the most effective means to
achieve them you're being rational
that's I think the best way of thinking
about rationality it's not the goals of
reasonable if that the means to achieve
the goals are effective